even the might of the Hulk is no match
for the power of all six Infinity stones
during a recent Twitter Q&A with wired
Avengers and game directors Jaron
Anthony Russo revealed the reason the
green Goliath failed to heal after using
the stones to resurrect the dusted
heroes in the film's final act simply
puts the combined power of the stones
would have been too much for virtually
any being in existence to handle and the
Bruce Banner is probably lucky to still
be breathing you'll remember that an
endgame banner volunteered to use the
stones housed inside a
brand-spanking-new Tony Stark built
Infinity Gauntlet 2.0 to reverse the
destruction wrought by thanassis
infamous nap other conclusion of
Avengers infinity war banner was
convinced of his destiny by the stones
radiation signature which was mostly
gamma the same type of radiation than
doubt him with the power of the Hulk
[Music]
was made for us
but his snap while successful took a
terrible toll the arm on which he wore
the gauntlet was seen to be largely
useless after his heroic action and fans
look to the Russos to explain why such a
powerful being would suffer such
shocking consequences from using the
stones twitter user Victor stone Mead
McGinn tweeted : Hulk has a hole healing
factor when his arm heal Anthony Russo
replied that healing factor or no using
the combined power of the stones are
simply too much for any being to walk
away from even Thanos who famously
slapped the Hulk around like a rag doll
in the opening scene of infinity war Joe
Russo explained the whole cos never come
up against every infinity stone in a
gauntlet and the pure power of the
stones Thanos is nearly invincible and
he did not heal either so clearly when
you wield the power of the Infinity
stones it does a rapper abort damage to
your being then Anthony Russo added
quotes if it doesn't even kill you all
too soon man rest in peace mr. stuck
anywho the easter acting duo also offers
some insights as to what led bana to
merge the two halves of himself which
was a crucial development
considering that it's likely that nobody
would have been able to talk the Hulk
into wielding the stark gauntlets had he
not been possessed savannas personality
and intellect 18 months in a gambler I
put the brains and the Brawn together
and now they give me
best of both worlds Anthony Russo
explained we wanted to track how every
single one of the Avengers was moving
forward from the experience of infinity
war and banner had this very unique
experience where in the opening of
infinity war he loses to Thanos as a
Hulk and later in the film he loses to
Thanos as banner
and so he is left with this reality that
neither version of himself could stop
Thanos so in the five-year time jump
that happens early on in endgame he sort
of dedicates himself to trying to better
himself so that this never happens again
and that's sort of the proper motivation
for him to finally figure out how to
reconcile the two sides of himself it
was a brutal but necessary outcome for
the mightiest Avenger and the one that
will have a lasting impact the Russos
have got him record stating that as far
as they're concerned the hoax injuries
are permanent
meaning that if bono were to make any
future appearances in the MCU which he
almost certainly will he may be
decidedly sidelined when it comes to
throwing down with super-powered
adversaries we say may because as you
may have heard the Russos have finished
directing MCU pictures for the
foreseeable future and it's not as if
another director can come up with some
plot device by which to heal the green
goliaths injuries although should banner
actually remain sidelines but even fade
from the picture entirely it's pretty
certain that his legacy will remain for
the selfless action he took to undo the
deaths of millions he'll always be among
the greatest heroes of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe and somehow we find
it likely that moviegoers haven't heard
the words Hulk smash for the last time I
think it's good to notice but whatever
[Music]
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos but
your favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and to
the Bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]